[Music]
here we go again Sony have revealed the
free games for PS Plus subscribers for
the month of March 2020 I'm really
interested to know what you think about
these ones you can get your grubby mitts
on these from Tuesday the 3rd of March
this intro is too long
let's do this well would you look at the
first game of the month its Shadow of
the Colossus I'll be honest right away I
love this game I hope you do too first
released on the ps2 in 2005 then
remastered on ps4 in 2018 Shadow of the
Colossus is a hugely unique game with
one of the most heartbreaking stories
ever without being told what to do you
quickly discover to save the woman in
the opening cinematic you must slay 16
colossi sounds simple right well each
Colossus is a living breathing moving
puzzle the size of a skyscraper
observing the beasts movements and
planning a route to climb to the sweet
spot is the core mechanic here hanging
on to its hair and watching your stamina
deplete as you scramble to the next safe
point is nerve jangling each Colossus
is completely unique oh and that ending
right in the fields please try this game
I beg you
it'd take you around 7 hours on a casual
playthrough and should you get stuck I
have a boss guide for you for each of
the 16 colossi I know there are some
platinum trophy hunters out there the
reviews for the game are off the charts
Shadow of the Colossus is an all-time
great there is no reason not to download
it I hope you love it too next up we
have a Sonic the Hedgehog game to
coincide with the new movie I'll tell
you now the movie is far better than
this game this is sonic force's typical
story dr. Robotnik or Eggman if that's
your jam and his cronies do battle with
Sonic and his friends throughout 2d
style and full 3d levels he is the best
bit we can create our own sonic
character playing as your own creation
we'll see you take on unique powers
thanks to weapons known as wisp ons
which grant different abilities like
flamethrowers are a new way to traverse
the level on top of this your players
two versions of the blue devil the
classic 2d Runner and the modern version
with more dynamic camera
I usually try my best to be positive but
I found sonic force is so annoying and
infuriating that I never finished it
there's a strange double jump which
doesn't always work than this the
gravity just feels weird it takes time
to get used to if you have Sonic mania
you should play that instead of this but
if you need a story with a few chuckles
and a great customization mechanic with
varied level designs sonic forces could
be the one for you
reviews cars have this at about six out
of ten very average so there's our fill
for the month how do you feel about it
please let me know in the comments and
remember leaving a Down bolt doesn't
send a message to Sony it simply kills
my channel rip with a dream I'm gonna
jump back into Shadow of the Colossus
cuz that's a great game but what about
you
I'm Adam from PlayStation granade if you
got this far please let me know if
you're planning on buying a PS 5 this
year or will you wait see ya
[Music]